Why did Salman find the need to twist
the story and release audio recordings
which I have messages which we're going
to hear recordings right now of
Muhammad claiming that Salman took an
oath by Allah that he's not recording
him by Allah by Allah and number two
we're going to read messages of Muhammad
Tonah saying to Salman leave me out of
this situation I don't want to be
involved
Not because he's blackmailed. Not
because he's blackmailed. And I am about
to prove that. Brothers and sisters,
let's hear the first recording for
ourself. Inshallah. When this matter was
brought up, I asked him
specifically, is this called is it
recorded? He said to me, "No." Then he
made an oath by Allah. That's not
recorded. He just wanted a crazy for
himself. He mentioned that it isn't
recorded. Then he made an oath by Allah.
Not only did Salman
backstab, he threw him under the bus.
Why did he do this? This is the big
question. Why did he do that?
Brothers and sisters and dear friends in
this video inshallah I'm going to be
answering um the questions that people
had the clarifications the
misinformation the slanders that have
been done towards ourself that we have
done a heinous heinous crime which is
blackmailing our own teacher so much so
the blackmailing was so severe that he
ended up in the hospital. This is the
version of Salman. This version and why
did he find the need to do this which he
thought was a golden bullet in the head
of myself and Muhammad for that matter?
He thought the matter is done. These
guys blackmailing the own teacher. You
cannot become the lowest of the law. You
cannot get any lower than that. And I
agree with him from his point of view
and the accusation that he's made, how
the public saw it to one for one to
blackmail their teacher to a level that
he ends up in hospital sending a voice
recording to Tony that he has ended up
in hospital is the most vilest
disgusting thing ever. Just one thing
though, if it is true that is the most
heinous crime of it all. So much so that
I am willing to leave the da scene
completely if this is true and I swear
swear upon Allah I swear by Allah I
swear upon the of thea and I ask Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to curse me and I ask
and I messaged them both as well and I
asked them to come get on a phone call
with me and ask the curse of Allah yes
I'll ask the curse of Allah on myself if
I'm lying and I asked him asked him
specifically Salman if I am lying on
this matter And he knows I am not.
Brothers and sisters, I'm about to show
receipts because I know everybody says
wall by Allah. You know Salman with his
calm tone and by Allah by Allah and by
Allah. You think to yourself somebody
who takes an oath. Surely he will not
lie. One thing that you guys have missed
out brothers and sisters is the
following. Alone said in order for you
to know what justice is, you have to
hear the other side. And this the reason
why brothers and sisters, I took 10 days
out. I consulted with my elders. I
consulted with brothers that I know. I
even sat down with Muhammad, Taron,
myself face to face with three
witnesses. And I'm going to tell you
what exactly unfolded. And I from the
best of my ability, I'm not going to try
to bring up things because I don't want
to harm his family. I want this to be
done in a in the Sharia council. And I
will tell you why he really ended up in
hospital and if he ever was blackmailed.
We are going to come to that inshallah.
So brothers and sisters that's first
thing first inshallah moving forward
brothers and sisters why did Salman find
the need to twist this story and release
audio recordings which I have messages
which we're going to hear recordings
right now of Muhammad tone claiming that
Salman took an oath by Allah that he's
not recording him and number two we're
going to read messages of Muhammad
tone saying to Salman leave me out of
this situation. I don't want to be
involved. Not because he's blackmailed.
Not because he's blackmailed. And I'm
about to prove that. Brothers and
sisters, let's hear the first recording
for ourself. Inshallah. When this matter
was brought up, I asked him
specifically. Is this called is it
recorded? He said to me, "No." Then he
made a note by Allah that's not
recorded. He just wanted a crazy for
himself.
So anyway, he mentioned that it wasn't
recorded when he made an oath by Allah
that it wasn't
recorded. That's one thing on the other
side. I mean it you
know the when he was asking about
specific details I was just only
avoiding more you know the answers but
at the end of the day I mean I you know
eventually if it's a testimony the
people will testify what they know even
though it's
nothing. So I told him and for you to
know there's nothing for me I'm not
obliged to answer your questions and at
the end of the day I have helped the
sister in the best way I
can and um and that's what I did and ask
her I did my best to help her that's all
uh so basically this is the that was the
conversation about about that now when
the voice of you heard brothers and
Sisters, Muhammad Tal is saying that
Salman took an oath by Allah. The man on
video who says by Allah, by Allah, by
Allah, by Allah, by Allah, by Allah,
with a calm tone, this man took an oath
by Allah that he is not
recording. Little did Muhammad know, not
only was he secretly recording him, he
also published the recordings which you
guys heard. Yes. which he which you
heard um and here is Muhammad pleading
with him in messages which I want to
show you guys in this is Salman
messaging him you sent him using you in
an effort to be a way a witness of a
false narrative and attack campaign
against myself and sister Bushra but
this is Allah's way of honoring you have
to go through the initial test but then
the relief and the reward comes
immediately after I will defend your
name and your honor in a way you never
thought possible I can't believe how
Muhammad hijab literally set his own
trap and fell in it. Do not be stressed.
You will see in two days what will
happen. Allah loves the sincere and the
truthful. May Allah expose and humiliate
the liars transgressors. Muhammad
replies salam brother. My brother you
brought me up in your video when I
clearly said to you that I don't want to
get involved. Says I referenced a
well-known sheh and had nothing
identical or anything referenced to
anyone that could tie to you. This is
critical due to their insistence that
there is nothing of merit. And then
Muhammad Alam replies
again brother as I mentioned to you I
don't want to get involved in this
matter and you are trying to pull me
into it the problem is no one is
benefiting from it except the enemies of
Islam look at the Shia the uh the
Zionist what are they doing they're
attacking all of us not just Muhammad
hijab especially the people of the
Islamic Sunni Tawa and please brother I
ask you by Allah do not bring me into
this matter in any way as I don't want
you or anyone to defend me I believe
Allah will defend the ones who was being
wronged not only did Salman and
backstabbed Ton. He threw him under the
bus. Why did he do this? This is the big
question. Why did he do that? Because
when I released my version of the video,
yes, that went viral and I talked about
how I sat down with the sister and I
interviewed her and I was supposed to
put the interview up and the the tide
swiftly changed. It changed towards
Salman being attacked because people
saying firstly, where is your evidence?
You have no evidence. Muhammad was not a
witness for the this so-called marriage
at nothing. As I said to you, I was not
involved in the between Muhammad hijab
and the sister Bush in any sort of form.
I was not her. I was not a witness. I
wasn't involved in that
nikah. So as I mentioned to you my
brother, I don't want to get involved
with this matter. I have done enough in
it. So please, you know, take me out of
this matter.
Muhammad Ton is talking about what Bush
is sister Bushra testified. Okay. So
there was no evidence. So
what Salman did next was he thought to
himself okay how can I further because
his integrity is in question now. So he
thought how do I get back at them? What
did he do? He recorded he um he released
a recording of between me and Sister
Busha which he was secretly recording.
No problem at all. You heard the
recording for yourself. If anything in
that recording, I was actually attacking
Muhammad hijab in that matter. If if I
am biased, why would I do that? Why
would I ask to go public? Which shows
that I was not biased and Allah is my
witness. I was not biased. I heard a
story until I heard the other side and
realized that she was not only lying
then she was allying with the enemies of
Islam and going and giving information
to the most heinous enemies of Islam.
Subhan Allah. So that's why I refused to
release it. Now Salman realized that's
not enough. Then he brought the
so-called father into the matter of
Bushra's father apparently and if you go
with the narrative Bushra telling
Bushra's father telling her do not marry
me you have no permission so it wasn't
working Salman needed a golden bullet
and that golden bullet would have come
how by by sacrificing Muhammad and he
realized oh my gosh the mistake that I
made not only that brothers and sisters
if you guys remember one of the claims
that was made by Salman was Her
testimony is her evidence. That's where
I did a video and talking about Salman's
ex. And if we said, "Okay, Salman, if
this is your condition, then does that
mean Duna's testimony is her evidence
against you and her heinous accusations
about you?" But what did Salman do?
Salman said, "Of course not." You know
what he did, brothers and sisters? Let's
read for ourselves. He made a mere
simple post, not a video, a simple post
saying the following. Correction on a
personal testimony as evidence in Islam.
Listen carefully guys. We would like to
correct an earlier point regarding the
victim's personal testimony and Islamic
legal procedures. A claimant's own
statement is not considered valid
evidence by on its own. The
clarification is important. One of our
team members members made an innocent
mistake. That being said, while her
statement may not meet Islamic legal
thresholds, it still holds enormous
moral and spiritual significance,
especially in a community where doors of
justice are closed. When for formal inst
institutions fail, Allah's door remains
open. The oppressed are granted a
powerful weapon. Dua that reaches the
heavens without a veil. Now, somebody
made a very important comment there. So,
whoa, hold on a second there. While her,
this is them repeating what Salman said.
While her statement may not meet the
Islamic legal threshold, they still hold
enormous moral and spiritual
significance. If you're a Muslim, Islam
is your only moral compass and it's your
spiritual compass. So, if it does not
meet an Islamic threshold, then it
doesn't meet moral or spiritual
standards either. If you call yourself a
Muslim, correct? Yes. Unless you believe
there is a morality outside of Islam
which is superior to Islam's morality
then you have fallen into kufur. So I
repeat one last time if it doesn't reach
an Islamic standard then it reaches no
standards without worth considering. So
clearly demonstrating that Salman are
you what are you trying to say that it
doesn't reach an Islamic threshold but
you're still going to go ahead with it.
That's like that's basically saying it
doesn't reach the Islamic threshold but
we are still going to take your
evidence. Whoa. My friend, you will get
lashed for slander. Now my point is not
this guys. The whole hijab I've done a
video done and dusted. Now Salman needed
a bullet, golden bullet to put this to
the end. What did he do? He decided to
sacrifice the very man our ex teacher
Muhammad and he sacrificed him and
backstabbed him by releasing an
information which was in
confidentiality. Yes. about hijabs,
family members, all this kind of stuff,
etc. Whatever it is for that matter.
Yeah. His wife, which Muhammad broke
confidentiality. If I go to a marriage
counselor, which he was, Muhammad did a
marriage counseling for me and my wife,
hijab and his wife to go and tell
certain things about our he's known to
do this many times to somebody that is
not even a scholar, who's some kind of a
journalist, broke confidentiality. But
not only that, what Salman did not know
was that because he did not know and he
was in a desperate situation to have one
over us and which it seemed before I
released this video that he definitely
had that one over him. Blackmailing our
teacher, he ended up in the hospital. He
little did he know because he doesn't
know Muhammad. I have spent I've lived
like said you cannot vouch for anybody
speak good or bad of them unless you
have traveled with them, lived with them
or worked with them. One of these three.
I know Muhammad Haron for 10 plus years,
nearly a decade. Nearly a decade.
Salman, because of your desperation,
because of your obsession with dunya and
whatever she put you through. Yes, you
made your whole dunya dunya. And this
has clouded your judgment judgment for
justice. And let me be honest, I am
embarrassed on your on your behalf of
what I'm about to reveal because I had
no choice but to do this. And I swear
upon Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala
curse me if I have ever blackmailed
Muhammad. If he ended up in hospital
because of so-called blackmailing this
is absolutely lie and I will come to on
camera with Muhammad whoever to say that
wall he has sat in this house in my own
house and I spoke to him. Yes. And let
me tell you something brothers and
sisters and everything is about to make
sense. The things that I'm going to show
you guys brothers and sisters is not
something that I want to and not only
that I have also censored for the sake
of Muhammad Taran's family and also for
the wellbeing of his children that I've
met in person and I am going to tell you
guys why I had no choice but to do this
brothers and sisters. So number one, I
challenged Salman to come on a phone
call with me that I will take Allah's
curse upon me if I am lying about what
I'm saying about any of this stuff. If
if it's a single lie, I ask anyone to
come and ask Allah's curse on the self
and ask myself if anything I'm saying
here is a lie. That's how certain and
sure I am of this matter. Not only that,
I have been directly blackmailed with
slanderous lies about myself and that a
organization that I'm working with will
be slandered also if I release this
video. And I said to the person who
slandered me to my blackmailed me to my
face
that I don't care whatever you think you
have over me because you have nothing
and I know alhamdulillah you have
nothing. I am going to come out with
this video and I'm going to come out for
specific reasons. So brothers and
sisters on this next chapter I'm going
to reveal to you guys why Ahmed really
ended up in hospital and how everything
is going to make perfect sense. Not only
that, it's going to leave Salman in a
big big dilemma. Tell you guys
why I've been holding this back for a
while and you're going to find out. Now
we're going to go back to 2019 guys 2019
we had our organization non for profit
organization Salah and in that non for
profofit organization brother and
sisters we had members who were involved
who started it
myself Muhammad Mahame hijab um what the
initial individuals who are in this
organization now brothers and sisters in
the da scene um we need to understand
that it comes with great amount great
responsibilities we cannot abuse our
power we cannot abuse our position and
take advantage of people we cannot
whoever it is and I'm talking generally
by the way I'm not talking anyone
specifically if you look at surah abasa
in the Quran Allah subhana wa ta'ala
rebukes the prophetam for frowning at a
blind man now the question we need to
ask is the blind man cannot see the
frowning why did Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala rebuke the prophetam because it
doesn't befit a prophet to frown even
though it is something so light but he
should have not done that sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the best man to walk
this earth brothers and sisters in the
da scene the Same thing applies. We have
to know better. There are certain things
that individuals can do, a layman can
Muslim can do that we cannot do because
it is the ama of the people given to us,
the money that they donate that we use
for the causes inshallah for the sake of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. The trust, the
belief that they they they they have in
us. That's the reason why when people
were messaging me and saying you
blackmail the teacher, it really hurt
me. And I didn't really blame them. I
wish they just came and asked me what
really happened. and when they see this
video, I know they're going to be
feeling maybe embarrassed and shy, but I
don't totally blame them. But if only
they just assumed the best and ask
questions rather than jump into
accusations. In 2019, brothers and
sisters, a um investigation um
accusations started to arise. Yes. So,
alleged harassment and confessions of
misconduct started to appear. Here is my
message to Muhammad Taron in 2019, 25th
of June 2019.
I've been told not to speak to anyone or
yourself until she man gets to the
bottom of it. There are allegations and
I am in Turkey. So, I'll wait for an
update. I can't do anything at the
moment. And then again, I can't show you
his reply cuz there's an ama. Yes, I
can't do what Salman does by taking
oaths and betraying it and showing
messages, etc. Yes, from his side. I
can't do that. Throwing talon under the
bus. Little does he know that that
golden bullet that he thought he's going
to use was a bullet that was it went to
his head instead of us because right now
the investigation that external
investigation going on which I'm going
to come to now is going to be submitted
to a genuine Sharia council and it's
also going to be submitted the people
are doing this who they've come to me
for witness testimony as well which I
have no choice but to do it's the huck
of the people they're also going to be
submitted to behind the veils and behind
the veils salman you are going to now
have to be impartial not biased and
released videos uh about the situation
about Muhammad Ton. The man that he
praised and said he's a scholar is in
doubt. And once again, I'm not trying to
say he's absolutely evil. I'm just
saying that there was misconduct. Uh
there was confessions of misconduct uh
um alleged harassment by free four
organizations, some of them are mosques,
10 plus testimonies, text messages which
I'm going to read and not disclose
because I don't want to harm his family.
I have to do this because it is
something that has happened many times
and you will understand now. We will
defend everyone's honor and yours and
everyone's also. Now when the
investigation was kind of concluded and
we saw the evidences, I said the
following. Now I want to tell one thing
guys. People think that this whole
arised because of speaking out against
hijab and I had hijab's back. Muhammad
Taran knows and he can vouch for me. He
knows what kind of person I am. He can
vouch for me. Yes. That I have nothing
personal against him. He's helped me in
many situations and I've helped him as
well. But this is not personal. This is
specifically for the sake of Allah
subhanaa tala. Why? Because there was a
moment at salam when Muhammad hijab
actually said something insulting to yes
out of moment of anger. They had their
disagreement and I I and this was when
hijab was at his most prominent. Yes.
The whole David Wood debate etc. Yes.
I'm not a yes man. I'm not a yes man. If
there's one thing that people know about
me da man I worked with many people. I'm
not a yes man. I'm not here to serve
anybody. My loyalty is to nobody except
Allah and his messenger. Yes. So when he
did that, I boycotted Muhammad. I told
him, you cannot speak to uh speak to him
like that. I boycotted him. Muhammad was
very upset. Whatever it is for that
matter. So I've defended Muhammad many
times. So I have no bias towards
anybody. But when these things arose
about him and sisters, this is what I
said to him and this is where you know
that I have the genuine concern of the
dowi. I'm sorry but this is not
justified at all and I saw the evidences
for myself and there was more than a
statement of I cannot disclose guys
because I believe this can harm him and
his family. So I don't want to go into
detail. I'm very disappointed and feel
disgusted. I feel used cuz I trusted
you. I do not wish bad for you but I
will never from now on ever endorse
anyone. These sisters will blame me and
say Alli, you promoted this person. You
called him your teacher. It's five
sisters, not only one. We are all men
and have weaknesses towards opposite
gender. But we are at the forefront of
the daer. We can't afford to slip up. If
I believe I'm vulnerable, I just move
away from the da and tell people I'm
struggling and would be taking a step
back from the da. So don't hold me to
account if I slip up. I have to now
message all these sisters and tell them
that I am free from anyone I endorsed,
including you. I don't trust anyone. I'm
no angel and I have had my mistakes. But
not to this level of multiple sisters
coming with similar things of being
inappropriate. Now brothers and sisters,
I want to make something
clear. There was no major sin involved.
I'm not saying that he did something of
sexual harassment. I want to make this
clear. It's no sexual harassment.
Nothing like that. But you need to
understand guys, like I said to you
before, there are certain things in the
da that we especially someone who deems
himself to be a teacher that he should
not do and not talk in a specific manner
in a specific way. One of those things
is sinful on his behalf and he knows
that. But other than that, there's
harassment accusations. I just want to
make that clear. I don't want people to
start going into wild accusations. No.
So I wrote there and these are the
sisters who saw you as a teacher and
trusted you. I defended you when all
this came out and I said I will not
believe a single word until I see full
evidences. Then we postponed the
evidence to meet you and hear your side
but you have resigned which shows me
your guilt. I do not wish to work or
trust anyone again so easily. We want
full want full reference and vouch from
people. I'm not ungrateful and I thank
you for what you've done for me. But
imagine if five sisters came out about
me. This is nothing personal but
strictly for the sake of Allah subhanaa
tala. I ask Allah to rectify your
affairs and I would highly recommend you
do you do not work with sisters at all
as it's your weakness like mine also
every man's but I have a I have measures
in place to protect myself especially
with what's going on with Hassanat
abusing his power. This was the time if
you remember with the whole Hassan
situation. We will be absolute
hypocrites to turn a blind eye to this
and carry on working with you in any way
shape or form. You even deceive me. I
don't understand why you why you like
people calling yourself a sheh and you
always want to be at the forefront and
want your pictures on top. This is
arrogance to me. But for the sake of
Allah, I turned a blind eye out. But now
abusing your power in I'm I'm disgusted.
Assalamu alaykum. He had his reprise
etc. etc. And then this is what I said.
I never took anyone's side. I defended
you. Never took anyone's side. I said I
want to hear his side. There is five
sisters not one. And then I wrote, you
can see cuz I can't give context because
reply. Why not man? You said certain
things to an individual, someone that he
wanted to marry. I've seen it all. You
told her again I need to blur this guys
because it's going to the Sharia
council. I do not want to go into
details. You said d and you
even on the phone also five other
sisters said certain whatever whatever
whatever. I'm not going to go into the
details of the message cuz this is going
to be submitted to the Sharia council
and also going to be submitted to behind
the veils of the investigation that's
going on and um I'm going to leave it to
that because I don't want to go and
again I'm not saying there was sexual
harassment z I'm not saying that I'm
saying there was misconduct and also
confessions of misconduct and also
alleged harassment by multiple people
multiple people and many other students
that used to work with them stopped
working with So much so brothers and
sisters that when this happened I freed
myself from in 2019. So for anyone that
says that this was something that we
prop orchestrated and got four
organizations and many people to come
together it's a grievious lie because
that was not the case in 2019. That's
what happened. I disted myself from him.
But then I was contacted by a person
that I deem to be a student of knowledge
who sat me down and said he's your
teacher and they tried to justify to me
what he did was not haram and whatever
whatever whatever I'm not going to go
into detail and they made me feel as if
what I doing was wrong and that I have
no right to boycott him and that I
should work with him and I should
apologize for that matter. I was in
double mind cuz to me I was like look we
cannot have these little even if it's
small mistakes or whatever it is and
some of them are sinful we can have a
dowy because he is known to be my
teacher me and Muhammad made him ah and
with all due respect he's not ah he's a
student of knowledge just like many
students of knowledge so this is the
reason why now what happened is I was at
speaker's corner around 2022 if I'm not
mistaken around that time three sisters
came to me complaining about
again. Now I was so disturbed. I was
like, "Oh my gosh, not again." Like I I
thought to myself like is this happening
again? Cuz even though I freed myself
and then what happened is they made some
allegations whatever it is again. Yes,
you can call it um alleged harassment
whatever for that matter. Okay. But this
time when I approached Muhammad Taron he
gave me counter evidence. Now the
counter evidence was somehow you can say
cleared him somehow to an extent. again
it was anyways I thought you know what I
spoke to that student of knowledge and
maybe I should assume the best maybe
should assume the best and leave this
matter I actually apologized the talent
I said you know what people make
mistakes they're human beings no problem
and this is my apology to him so you
guys can read it for yourself now in 5th
January 2020 yes if we plotted all of
this is these lies I'm making this stuff
up four sisters this is what I'm talking
about four sisters came to me today
complaining about you and saying you
again alleged harassment. I'm not going
to show um whatever whatever whatever I
can't go into detail with them. A rever
sister said you again I have to blur
this for the sake of his family. I'm not
going to go in detail. I have no choice
now but to take this as a sign that
something's not right about you. This is
the third time because I promoted you.
They're complaining to me now brothers
and sisters when I did this he some
context or whatever whatever whatever
and even you can see on 14th of May I
blocked him I blocked him because this
is to me it's a it's an ama I blocked
him but what happened is there were some
evidences uh brought to me etc and um
because of that I apologized to him and
I just want to read it to you guys.
Yeah. On the 30th of July 2020 when the
evidence was brought forth and when I
thought to myself you know what let me
assume the best in him I saidamikum I
would like to ask your forgiveness for
assuming the worst in you. I just had a
concern for our sisters and also when
the recent controversy happened with the
hassad issue I panicked and I wasn't
thinking clear and when the sisters
started crying I felt very bad and took
the matters into my own hands. I had the
concern of Muslims at heart and mis
misjudged. So please forgive me because
you showed the messages these sisters
sent you after leaving Umrah. If that if
what they accused you of was true then
they would never ever send you those
well-wishing messages. Saka you can see
I apologize when because if they are
complaining about him then why did they
send him well-wishing messages if that's
really the case. So again I don't know
if these messages were directly from
them I assume the best. This was the
third instance that this happened. Yes.
Now brothers and sisters a month before
or three four weeks before the whole
Salman videos came out there was a again
a um alleged harassment uh happened
again when I heard this I was like like
what do I do like this time like it's
just like you know the prophet said the
believer doesn't get bit from the same
hole twice what do I do brothers and
sisters then I I know some people think
okay hold on a second how come the
timing
And I asked Allah subhana wa tala to
deal with me.
If I blackmailed or I was involved in
something to hush him or something he
knew. Muhammad was not even a witness to
the marriage. He does not know nothing
and it's irrelevant. The point was what?
Salman needed a golden bullet and he
used voice note after taking it off by
Allah. You know he says by Allah by
Allah. Can you imagine how deceitful you
have to be by taking it off by Allah and
releasing all your when he told you he
doesn't want to be involved? And the
reason he didn't want to be involved,
brother sisters, is let me tell you
brothers and sisters because Muhammad Al
knew there's an investigation going on
before Salman's videos. So we could not
orchestrate this. We got enough 10 plus
people coming forward of harassment. Um
more organizations I can't name for
legal reasons. Yes. that are some of
them are taking external u independent
investigation that's going on of this
it's going to be submitted to Sharia
council it's going to be submitted to
behind the veils yes okay so brothers
and sisters all of this is going on now
you need to understand when that
happened yes I did the same thing the
video that was released by Salman was on
the 6th of April the
investigation that started by two
sisters not by myself by Muhammad hijab
two sisters came forward and an
investigation happened which one is I
cannot go into for legal reasons the
other one is being carried out it's
going to be submitted to Sharia council
and this is my message on you can see
the date 11th February to shame if my
I'm with my wife she I can't talk as
it's a private matter and now involves
allegations about you and now the
organization is being brought into this
the messages I'm reading guys again I'm
doing this because I we're being accused
of blackmailing our teacher who ended up
in hospital the real reason he ended up
in hospital is because for the third or
fourth time these alleged harassments
and not only that he confessed to me of
his misconduct in 2019 came out. So
because of this and he thought this was
because of the whole hijab situation.
Brothers and sisters the video was
released on 6th of April. This started
this investigation started this
complaints again came back on 11th
February that's two months ago before
any Salman video. So I had no personal
issues with at all. I had no plan of
doing this until the whole allegation of
blackmailing. He ended up in hospital
and the sisters coming forward. I had I
have an opportunity a obligation to
clear my name. I've never blackmailed
him. Number two, which I've proved to
you guys why he really ended up in
hospital. And number three, my dear
brothers and sisters, if this harassment
is the truth, that's the fourth time
it's happened. I have to free myself
from him. With all due respect, wall, it
is purely for the sake of Allah. I have
nothing personal against him. He's
helped me so many times and I've helped
him as well. But it's not about that.
Look, I'm not here to defend anybody.
But one thing is clear. If your name is
dragged in dirt by some journalist
Salman, you have a right to be upset to
the person that you know who's going and
feeding him information when he's not
himself informed which he doesn't know.
He's heard one side of the story. As a
human being, looking from a hijab side,
he has a right to be upset. Hijab did
not say if you don't do this I'm going
to bring your dirt out or whatever.
Nothing like that was said. So number
one the investigation happened two
months ago and it is still ongoing by
the way. Yes the this is the reason why
he genuinely ended up in hospital and he
was never blackmail. Now let me tell you
something guys. I sat with Muhammad
Taron before making this video and I
told him I'm going to go public because
I because of this heinous allegations
and because of the alleged harassments
of the sisters coming forward and I'm
not going to go into much detail but
what I'm going to say is this. I have
three witnesses. Two two two are his
students. Two of them was his students
or ex students should I say. Yeah. One
of them. One of them he knows. Yes. Let
me put it like this without going into
detail without mentioning who. I was
directly blackmailed. Now when you're
talking about blackmail, guys, I'm
talking about fullblown direct blackmail
and these three people I will come as a
witness if anybody denies this there
will be slanderous accusations made
about me and about an organization that
I'm working about. And I said you know
what I fear no one but Allah subhana
tala. If you think whoever made this I'm
not going to go in detail. Why? Because
I just want to protect the dignity and
honor. I'm not going to go into details.
Free witnesses are there. free righteous
people. Alhamdulillah that will testify
and one is from um Muhammad side who
witnessed what happened. Yes, I want to
make this very clear guys and I want to
end this chapter that I never ever
blackmail him ever. I've not enough to
blackmail him and never and even if I
did I would never do that. It's he to
your teacher. Number two, he ended up in
hospital because of since 2019 of these
alleged harassments going uh about him.
There's an investigation going. That's
why he ended up because he realized
multiple organizations are coming forth
of
complaints and 10 plus witnesses and we
got text messages all this kind of
stuff. That's why brothers and sisters
um that's why he went ended up in
hospital. And lastly, the reason I'm
doing this video is to free myself of
Muhammad which I did not want to because
I'm not going to be blamed for something
that he has done or he may have do he
may do. And I believe as a person who's
seen as a sheh a teacher to do stuff
like this no matter again it's not I'm
not saying he did major sin sexual
harassment no it does not be someone to
do that brother sisters inshallah lastly
but not least salman
um it shows me how reckless you are
because you have gone and betrayed
Muhammad used his recordings backstabbed
him just to get back at us so you can
have some credibility. Little did you
know that you know nothing about
Muhammad and I'm not saying he's an evil
guy. Yes, I ask Allah to
rectif you know that golden bullet was a
bullet in your head because now your
investigation has to be carried out
about Muhammad and if these allegations
which there's I mean the receipt said
I'm going to send it to the relevant
parties who are doing the investigation.
Now you are on a big big dilemma Salman
a massive dilemma. Your obsession with
dunya making dunya your whole dunya and
your rage like I said like I said before
it's like the resentment you have
towards dunya is as if you're drinking a
poison and expecting her to die and you
have brought your integrity to the floor
now by praising a man that you don't
know nothing about. You don't know
what's been going on. And now you're in
a dilemma. You praise him as you did.
You know nothing about him. But now the
investigation is carrying on and you're
going to have to release videos about
Muhammad and I ask Allah subhana wa
ta'ala to verify affairs and I ask
anybody anyone that thinks I'm lying I
ask Allah subhanaa tala I am ready to
take an oath if anything I said here was
a lie and
wall and I met Muhammad face to face
with free witnesses and he knows yes how
Salman backstabbed him how Salman took
an oath and lied and released his audio
recordings and free witnesses were a
witness cuz I wanted witnesses there.
And not only that, brother and sisters,
I was directly blackmailed in that
meeting. Directly blackmailed in that
meeting. And wall, I do not fear it.
Come out with whatever you want to come
out because no one's going to take
advantage of their position and abuse
it. Yes. No. No. No way. It's going to
happen. Not under my watch. I'm so
sorry. It's not going to happen.
Alhamdulillah. And I gave many chances.
And brothers and sisters, on that note,
I want to close this chapter. Salman
thought it was closed. But he's not
though this chapter is opened. I am now
closing this inshallah once and for all
in brothers and sisters again I don't
want anyone being hateful towards
Muhammad yes I don't want anyone
attacking I'm not here to do this I'm
just telling the reality of why I had to
come out and clarify of what really
happened and why he really ended up in
hospital and I said this to his face in
the meeting and I said you know it is
not true that you ended up in hospital
and he didn't even say that as far as I
know he didn't say he said he's in
hospital but he didn't say cuz he's a
black man as far as I Salman made this
all up. So he even knows and in the
meeting he did not even say no I did end
up. No he didn't. He knows he ended up
in there because of this investigation.
Brothers and
sisters, anything I said wrong is from
myself and anything good is from Allahh.
Backhead.